foreign
you only have two hours to do whatever
it is you're gonna do all right you have
to do the autopsy and immediately after
meet me at minters restaurant I need to
know what you find why did she say two
hours because we're in the mortician
they're going to put him in the ground
minter's restaurant after five
you've got to get him out of here yeah
we should get going Bert
Harold I don't know what you think
you're doing this excuse me hello
get a dead white man in a box
not even a casket
important man in a pine box of old wood
doesn't even have a top on it
his daughter's crying
who do you think's gonna get in trouble
here
the black man melt that's who right now
we need to get him our leader who
founded our regiment into the truck do
the autopsy
meet me at minter's restaurant
immediately after got it I need to know
I need to know what you found okay
five because please be careful it's got
a bum a wheel
not careful
this is why you'll never drive the Obama
is coming for this you better be here
two hours
you remember Bert don't you of course
Irma Sinclair hello Bert hello Irma
don't be nervous I do at least two
autopsies a month I've done two
autopsies my whole life one to prove I
didn't leave a clamp on someone's small
intestine the other to remove a clamp I
did leave on so much smaller intestine
now we know you're good with small
intestines but thank you
I'm zerman
friends milk
you know Irma his wife wouldn't stand up
for him to her family they haven't lived
together in over a year
I just want to see you happy that man
makes you realize time is short and Love
is Real if you know what it is
going on here autopsy paperwork
the police are waiting for this body to
return to the mortuary
sooner we start the sooner he's out
these two men need to leave immediately
they're veterans they served their
country go away we'll be downstairs
Irma's Portuguese that's different
I know you have a Portuguese
I'm not
do you want to start this or shall I
know what
you can just
support that's what Harold needs I can
help
they were such a kind man
there we go
oh God
um didn't ask how you were doing
my man left
this kind of thing happens every day
sorry
it's fine
through love is based on choice not need
do you need your wife or do you choose
your wife who can it be both no the
second one is the one that truly matters
at the end of the day it is
Choice matters over need
I don't like to be alone
oh
color
something yeah
given to him over a period of time it's
hard to tell how long
he just got back from Europe
I'll close him up and take more blood
samples I'll have more news for you
tomorrow I take it you're still at the
same office yeah
yeah Harold says you deserve a better
circumstance but you allowed yourself to
be corrupted he says you followed the
wrong God home
what corrupted oh the wrong God why
didn't he say that to me what does that
even mean I don't know
maybe you spend enthusiasms and
urgencies you didn't know you were
wasting until it was too late you ended
up without a chair by the time the music
ends
even in your own home
we need this room that's perfect because
we were just leaving
Liz said to meet her after five at
mentors right but I want to talk to you
about Irma
not push that burden because I want to
see it happen and I'm your friend my
friend who thinks I'm corrupted somehow
yet doesn't have the customer decency to
tell it to my face
to your face
you've got flowers for your wife who
won't let you live in your own apartment
explain the word corrupted or the terms
following the wrong guard home it's your
in-laws apparently they hate that we
work together let alone that we're
friends I don't listen to any of that
Park have a new garbage yes you do you
care a little bit and all it takes is a
little bit bird then they got you
like that drop of blood from the cuts
you got from the war before I stabbed
that German those cuts plotted your eye
and guess what you lost Fiat forever
oh we're actually meeting someone a tall
woman blind
yes serious face yes right this way
wait he was here I don't know what
happened
right there
she goes wait Miss Meekins
naked
let's begin
we did what you asked we found something
suspicious just like you can't do it
sorry
I spoke to her school friends
I have to be careful did he scare you he
said it was dangerous wait Mr Speaker
and you know what he used to say is he
used to say you can't run it from Fear
you can't let fear chase you around I
know that I seem afraid
and I shouldn't be because you're
supposed to caution at me he wasn't he
he meant well he's a friend of the
family what did you find
believe that he might have been poisoned
you know why is somebody watching me I
can't it's okay
I don't know if I can talk about this
[Music]
he knew something he saw something
terrible he did and they knew he was
gonna tell tell what did he
did he's dangerous
[Music]
to order the entire movie Amsterdam